Hall halli
hallo hallo S oder dier oder
soer ja wir haben hier einen
fantastischen Raum bekommen du darfst
Vorgehen gerne do wir sind ja ja in
einem Nobelhotel habe ich schon gemerkt
ja ich wusste überhaupt nicht dass das
hierer das Redon Blue ist ne du auch
nicht ne ne aber ich kann du vom Seen
halt ja ja man siehtmer so ein riesiges
Hochhaus wir gehen hier
durch und ja das ist das und hier sind
wir okay Simon deso ist bei uns wir
haben gerade überlegt wir lassen euch
kommentieren aber mit einer Frage bei
der es um Simon deso geht ihm ist keine
eingefallen aber mir ist ein eingefallen
und zwar in einem der letzten Videos
hast du überlegt ob ne ihr habt mit
deinem Freund habt ihr darüber
diskutiert wer sich wann wie die Haare
ab rasieren also meine Frage wäre wie
soll heimon demnächst seine Haare tragen
soll es so bleiben wie es ist soll er
sich den Kopf KL rasieren lassen oder
lieber offen
wir sind gespannt ich nehme an du auch
woh die Meinung so hintendiert bin ich
sehr vielleicht wäre das ja mal eine
super Typberatung ja das kann sein ne
weiß do nicht gut unsere erste Frage ich
weiß nicht kennst du die die erste Frage
die erste Frage es gibt immer also nah
zu
9,9% stelle ich immer die gleiche Frage
am
Anfang wie ist die Lage die Lage ja gut
sehr gut ja ich verstehe genau wie du
meinst aber von mir die Lage wie mir
gerade geht oder wie mhm gut gesättigt
schicken Wings alles okay und nicht im
Moment gestresst weil du ja deine
videofrequenz etwas erhöht
hast Stress ist vorbei sagen wir so vor
einer Woche noch ziemlich verstess aber
jetzt alles perfekt willst du denn das
noch mal machen so eine Aktion jeden Tag
ein Video nein
nein gar nicht ich sag mal so es war
anstrengend und immer manchmal war es
echt so knapp dass ich das nicht mal an
den Tag geschafft hätte weil man ich bin
ja jeden Tag zu Hause gewesen das war
das Problem aber Problem ich finde es
hat sich gelohnt es hat Spaß gemacht
andersit war hart aber deninger noch mal
drun nein Danke
und hast du denn denn nicht mal ein
bisschen was vorgedreht du hättest ja
auch sagen können ich drehe an einem Tag
mal fünf Videos vor oder ja ja das habe
ich auch überlegt also nicht dass ich
vordrehe aber diese Frage habe ich
gelesen in den Kommentaren weil ich lese
auch natürlich Kommentare durch hat so
ein Mädchen geschrieben irgendwie so mir
ist gerade eingefallen dass wir auch die
vorh aufnehmen können dann reinstellen
das war aber dann schon irgendwie der
282 oder so dann ist mir eingefallen ach
ich könnte ja immer so den Tag noch
sagen hier wir haben den und den Tag
also Kamera habe ich immer dabei ich
habe sie jetzt z.B auch dabei aber habe
ich nicht gemacht was hast du für eine
Kamera dass die so klein ist das immer
dabei das ist so eine darf ich
Schle flipo HD Ultra HD das ist ganz
schön geiles Teil kannst du mal angucken
ja du wirst lachen wir komoparieren mit
den weil wir nämich auch so super finden
und ich ma auch mein wenn ich
zwischendurch hier den Aufsager für
stellt Simon eure Frage die habe ich
auch mit der die ist auf jeden Fall gut
also ich kann mich nicht beklagen das
heißt damit hast du viel gedreht oder
wie hast du es gemacht dass du das
geschafft hast jeden Tag eine Idee und
das auch noch umsetzen also Idee habe
ich mir erstmal so ganz an Anfang
überlegt so ja ich k ja das und das
machen hat sich dann aber so
hingeschoben dass ich irgendwie gerade
noch an dem Tag so dachte so scheiße
morgen muss ein Video reinstellen was
mach du denn da und dann kam immer
irgendwie manchmal kam dumme Dinger
manchmal kam einfach nur Schwachsinn was
aber einfach extrem gut angekommen ist
also das war immer so auf den Freestyle
ja das heißt der Schwachsinn ist besser
angekommen der Schwachsinn ist sehr gut
angekommen okay was denkst Du dann üers
Publikum was denkst du hey Moment warum
mache ich mir die Mühe oder also ich sag
mal so wenn ich so überlege von der
Zuschauer aus würde ich auch sagen okay
dieses Video ist zwar eigentlich sinnlos
aber auch wiederum da dadurch dass es so
sinnlos ist wieder lustig weil man das
da so hochbringt das ja aber ist okay F
jetzt nicht so schlecht ne also youtube
ist ein bisschen unberechenbar youtube
ist schlimm ja youtube ist sehr schlimm
sag ich sag nicht ich mag nicht Youtube
aber youtube ist schon h okay aber was
ist das Schlimme an
Youtube das bei mir ist es so ich will
es nicht jemand schlecht machen aber ich
es gib
so Leute bei Youtube die mich nicht
mögen sage ich kommen ja so rüber also
die Hater die berühmten Hater ja ja und
die
stellen alles an damit irgendwie meine
Videos schlecht da stehen nur das sind
Leute die wirklich irgendwie 80 Accounts
machen und irgendwie da immer was
anderes schreiben und so wie Hass Videos
hochladen und so ich denke nur so hat er
nichts zu tun wenn ich sehe da gibt's
Leute die beiden sich gegenseitig obwohl
ich da ge zu ich les nur durch sag der
beleidigt den und der beleidigt den nur
weil der eine mein Video nicht mag und
der mag mein Video und dann aber es
lustig anzugucken also ich habe da kein
Problem solange sie ich nicht irgendwie
auf der Straße so abstechen oder so soll
BL Schleim ist weiß nicht habe ich
Schleim gesagt ich
meine streiten streiten streiten genau
streiten genau du bist du hier das ich
habe überlegt woher kommt der du bist du
in du sprichst perfekt deutsch aber bist
du in Deutschland aufgewachsen die ganze
Zeit oder
das schwer zu erklären ich habe bin also
eigentlich nicht schwer zu erklären ich
bin geboren hier in Deutschland dann war
ich 6 Jahre alt dann bin ich in die elfm
Küste gezogen da wo mein Vater
Herkt ein Jahr aber nur da geblieben und
dann wieder zurück weil sie wurde ich
eingeschu also sie woll sollte eingeschu
werden deswegen wieder zurück noch
Deutschland Schule halt in Deutschland
ist besser deswegen hier weiter
aufgewachsen und ja und daher kommt noch
Maline deutsche Sprache okay es gibt
eine Fake Bio im Netz da wird erzählt du
wärst in Brooklyn geboren du
kenst war schon etwas die war wirklich
krass also ich habe durchgelesen ich
habe die Geschick bekommen von irgend so
ein Fan und ich denke so wow das ja
wirklich so wie so Rapper Film oder so
ein Gangsterfilm ich denke cool ich
komme aus Amerika hey wusste ich gar
nicht aber schon lustig was man da so
findet und dann so in Afrika Aufentalt
Krieg Mutter nach Deutschland Kinder
allein alle Verwandtschaft glaube ich
erschossen irgendwie sowas also ganz
ganz merk aber die Geschichte an sich
war schon so es könnte so ein Drehbuch
sein eigentlich ne ja ja stimmt stimmt
wirst du schon mal auf der Straße
angesprochen oft sehr oft also letzte
Zeit also seit das angefang mit die
ganzen Hype krass also wirklich krass
aber ich fin's lustig also ich habe da
kein Problem ja ist es nicht auch
komisch wenn man plötzlich jahrelang
gehmer durchs Leben und keiner hat einen
sonderlich beachtet und pl
also ich sag mal so bei mir war es
früher immer so ich hatte die
auffälligsten Klamotten die man sich
vorstellen kann haben Leute mal geguckt
und jetzt ist einfach so für mich jetzt
kommen die zu mir reden mit mir machen
manchmal Fotos und aber es ist cool es
ist aber gut schon merkwürdig dass ich
dieses so nicht kann nicht ganz
realisieren wie viel das ist weil die
Leute sehen der Straße ich hatte mal ein
Mädchen die zu mir gekommen hat geweint
nein ehrlich sie kam Z oh mein Gott
geweint und ich
dachte bist du sicher dass du mit mir
redest ja Simon ich sag ich bin nicht
irgendwie so amerikanischer Wepper oder
so aber es ist schon echt verrückt
aber gut eine Umstellung man muss sich
dran gewöhnen aber ich finde ich habe
mich dran gewöhnt und es ist cool aber
es entwickelt sich weiter es wird noch
mehr also aber es ist wirklich wirklich
eigentlich ist es cool weil früher ich
sag mal so wenn ich wollte könnte ich
jetzt die ganzen Mädchen so haben sage
ich mal ne aber
ich tu es nicht warum weiß ich nicht ich
glaube ich musste da noch mal drüber
nachdenken das ist ein Punkt du bist in
einer guten Position m also man ich
könnte
ausnutzen aber nicht weil ich find's ich
find es eigentlich gutes Gefühl wenn
Leute zommen so das was man macht so
bestätigt wird von den Leuten also ist
cool aber wegen den Mädels machst du es
nicht nee also ich sag mal ganz ehrlich
ich habe damals angefangen so Videos zu
machen weil ich ich wollte einfach so
Eindruck schen bei Mädchen so ja
GU hat sich er dann so hingestellt dass
die Mädchen dachten so was ist das denn
für einer so aber jetzt wiederum ist es
so ich fin es echt lustig wenn die
Mädchen kommen und sagen hey s ich sag
hey du
aber ich nutz es nicht aus also aber
schon lustig man lernt dadurch auch echt
viele Leute kenen aber warum machst du
es dann wenn du es nicht für die Mädels
machst ich mach ich sag mal so ich habe
wie gesagt angefangen so weil ich
Eindruck schehen wollte bei mchen
so jetzt hat sich aber ganz geändert
weil ich einfach nur darus mache ich
habe Bock drauf und dann mache ich es
und wenn ich mal keine Lust habe dann
mache ich auch kein Video weil dann
sieht man das auch wenn ich keine Lust
habe und irgendwie nur so und wenn ich
ja es hat sich halt hingestellt einfach
ist mein Hobby es macht mir Spaß und
deswegen mache ich das also es hat jetzt
früher wie gesagt für Mädchen war es ne
jetzt ganz umgestellt einfach so weil es
mir Spaß macht und ich habe freue mich
daran was ich Erin mich an ein Video da
ging es um Spiele und der Hauptpreis
wäre gewesen dass
das Mädel mit dem du die Spiele gemacht
hast ja eine ich sag mal jetzt Youtube
fähig eine sexuelle Handlung an dir
begangen hätte ja
da war auch schon so das ist schon mein
Meinung gut frech gewesen viele Leute
dachten auch schon das wäre zu weit aber
ist ja nicht jetzt so gewesen das war ja
nur so dass wir die Leute denken so weiß
du das war so ein bisschen was denkst so
wo die Leute denken oh mein Gott das
macht er noch nicht wirklich aber also
das war schon gut an der Grenze und
weiter würde ich natürlich auch nicht
gehen aber da war auch schon so meine
Idee so h mach mal ein bisschen was
frecheres so ist aber auch gut
angekommen eigentlich ja also du willst
immer so ein bisschen an die Grenzen
gehen ja solange ich will so mich
darstellen wie ich bin und ich bin jetzt
nicht immer so extrem lieb ich kann
normal Person natürlich auch lieb aber
ich habe schon andere Seite die schon
bisschen frecher ist und da wollte ich
das mal zeigen und also die Leute wissen
schon auch dass ich so ein bisschen
frecher bin nur das war halt so ein d
das
war frech was hast du denn auf Youtube
noch vor 200.000
Abonnenten ich will erstmal ich weiß
nicht was ich was ich habe genaues
Youtube Ziel habe ich gar nicht ich will
ich kann es jetzt mal sagen
so was ganz heftiges reißen und zwar
jetzt noch nicht in der nächsten Zeit
aber wenn noch dieses Jahr auf jeden
Fall dass ich mit englischen Videos
anfangen wieder weil ich habe ganz fr
englische Videos gemacht genau und damit
aber und unter den Top weiß ich jetzt
nicht den Top 50 z.B kommen das
natürlich schwer die haben ja das ist
die haben ja lich die deutschen helf
aber selbst die können dann nur ja aber
ich habe schon gut mein Plan entwickelt
das wird dann auch so ein nicht so ein
Eingang sondern einfach so ein Boom so
ein reinhau Ding dass ich schon da
irgendwie an der Spitze also nicht an
der Spitze bin sondern so ein guten
Einklang dafür hab dass ich da was
erreichen kann das hei du hast was
überlegt was thematisch reinhaut oder ja
was ist deine Strategie ich habe ganz
viele Videoideen für die englischen
Videos wo ich weiß die es geht gar nicht
anders dass sie nicht ankommen es kann
nur so sein die natürlich nicht verraten
werde bestimmt jemand weil das ja das
kam aber ganz lustig weil ich habe
irgendwie so abends gar nichts getan
einfach so we ich mit me Freunden Bar
haben wir da so gesessen und war ich
gerade voll in meinen Gedanken drinneür
so ja du bist auf Youtube jetzt hast
schon was erreicht auf den deutschen
Ding und ich will immer irgendwie was
machen wo man denkt so cool und wenn ich
jetzt weitermachen würde wä irgendwann
glaube ich meine Meinung nach wä
irgendwann Schluss also jetzt nicht
Schluss ganz
sondern kann so abben so ja z.B was was
muss der ideale Youtuber drauf haben
oder wie muss der sein weil ich sag mal
es gibt ja ein anderen Erfolg her
Tutorial der ist ja komplett anders als
du aber der hat ja auch was was Erfolg
hat ja ja also ich sag mal so ich dis
nicht ne er ist ein cooler Typ wir haben
schreiben oftmals Internet zusammen ist
echt n netter Typ ich sag die Leute die
ihn gucken natürlich sind meine Meinung
nach ganz andere Leute die meine Videos
gucken aber Schnittmenge Null aber er
ist auf jeden Fall cooler Typ er macht
sein Ding also die Leute ich weiß nicht
ich weiß nicht ob die es feiern aber er
kriegt halt viele Leute die es gucken
und so viele Abonnenten hatte auch
respektiere ich also ist halt nur nicht
das was ich mache aber was muss man
haben ihr seid ganz verschieden aber
irgendwas müsst ihr beide haben was was
funktioniert ich kann dir den perfekten
Youtuber beschreiben der alles reisten
würde okay am besten jung ja am besten
sieht er so aus wie Justin Bieber z.B ja
okay so und irgendwie irgendwie wo die
Mädchen denken so oh ist so süß wo die
sowas denken der wird sofort da ganz
oben sein du musst irgendwie nur einmal
so ein Video machen so hey everything is
good und die wür un es feiern ja ne oder
du bist halt eine Frau hast ein bisschen
bisschen Ausschnitt und hängst im so und
redest einfach hat ja auch auch eine
Amerikanerin aber es gibt in Deutschland
gibt's das noch nicht Anfang des Jahres
da habe ich bin ich auf dich gestoßen
hat du glaube ich noch 11000 Abonnenten
und also war da da hattest du schon den
Plan oder warst du dir sicher dass du
das erreichen würdest zu diesem
Zeitpunkt oder weil da ging das ja schon
täglich mit 1000 neuen Abonnenten ab ich
will jetzt nicht sagen ja ich war mir
sicher aber ja ich war mir sicher weil
ich habe Ende 2009 mir geplant okay 2010
wird mein Jahr keiner kann mich daran
hinern dass dieses Jahr mir gehört sage
ich und ich habe allen meinen Freunden
gesagt dieses Jahr werde ihr sehen das
ist mein Jahr alle so ja ja ich bin
dabei jetzt sieht man ich wollte
eigentlich schon was erreichen auf
Youtube ne in 2010 so ein bisschen so ja
sage ich mal Ende des Jahres irendwie
100.000 Abonnenten muss mussten sein ist
jetzt bisschen bisschen früher bisschen
früher gekommen aber auf jeden Fall ich
wurde oft gelöscht das tut mir immer so
Herzen irgendwie warum WST du gelöscht
ja also ganz ganz früher war es so
Copyright urheberchte natürlich ist
natürlich klar ne respektiere ich auch
ja ist klar und dann gab's halt so
Dinger wo ich
nichts schlimmes gemacht habe aber
irgendwie wo das halt Leute nicht nicht
gut fanden und deswegen wur mein Account
gelöscht einmal war es halt so dass ich
ein neuen Account gemacht hatte okay
jetzt starte ich ich habe ein Video
reingestellt gar nichts war da und mein
Account war weg einfach so einfach
gelöscht ich denke das kann do nicht
sein wieso ich habe gar nichts getan ich
schreibbe Youtube an Kriege leider keine
Antwort aber na ja aber jetzt dieser
Erfolg was macht er mit deiner
Psyche besteht die Gefahr dass du
abhebst nein warum nicht ich sag ganz
ehrlich alle Leute die irgendwas
erreicht haben ich kenne Leute die so
Rapper die ein bisschen Bekanntheit
haben wo ich jetzt schon viel mehr habe
und die abgehomen sind und ich hatte
immer dieses ich will nicht arrogant
sein weil ich kann das gar nicht ab wenn
Leute denken so die sind was besser als
die anderen und ich bin nicht besseres
als die anderen vielleicht manchmal so
wenn ich irgendjemand sehe den ich gar
nicht mag dann sag ich ich bin besser
als der aber ich wollte nie irgendwie
arrogant oder eingebildet werden weil
das sind gerade genau das sind die Leute
die ich nicht mag und das war auch mein
Ziel falls ich irgendwas erreichen werde
dass ich nicht so wert wie die anderen
dass ich nicht irgendwie wenn jemand zu
mir kommt und sagt hey hey bist du nicht
der und der dass ich sage ja bin ich und
dann schau dann den hey cool reden wir
ein bisschen aber abheben ich hoffe ich
tu es nicht aber ich wer auch nicht weil
mein Kopf sagt das darf nicht aus werden
du hast auch ganz gute Technik habe ich
festgestellt ein Canon 5D ich hat mal
gemt super weil die die die Bilder hast
du dir das schon von deinem verdienten
Geld kaufen können oder Anmerkung Canon
5D Mark 2on das ist die ein bisschen
besser die mag gut die andere kannte ich
schon gar nicht mehr ja die mag du also
ich habe ich also ist natürlich echt
teuer das Ding mich es sich und ich habe
es von dem Geld gekauft was ich durch
dies ganze bekommen hab also schon das
Geld was ich irgendwie verdiene wenn ich
irgendwas mache steck ich schon da rein
dass Qualität besser wird oder dass ich
halt dadurch weil es interessiert mich
dass ich halt meine Interessen weiter
ausbauen kann das heißt das ist wirklich
deine Leidenschaft was du da machst auf
jeden Fall gut dann wüns ich dir dabei
viel Erfolg dass Du dabei bleiben kannst
weil ich glaub das ist das Schönste im
Leben wenn man seine Leidenschaft zum
Beruf machen kann auf jeden Fall und ich
hoffe es wird da es wird dazu kommen
aber ich denke schon ich werde irgendwas
einschlagen was mir wirklich Spaß bringt
und gut viel Glück danke
schön